i'm going to talk about where the
chemical elements come from if you want
something close to a symbol i'm going to
talk about the r-process and the
s-process we're gonna talk about chemical
elements which means i need to venture
alarmingly close to chemistry and
actually talk a little bit about the
periodic table so first let me show you
an astronomers periodic table which is
this
there are only three things in the
universe as far as astronomers are
concerned there's hydrogen helium and
everything else which we tend to call metals.
and the fraction of each we tend to call
x y&z i'm going to show you this because
it really annoys chemists but actually
to a large extent it's sort of helpful
because actually was one of the things
that astronomers broadly know is that
hydrogen and helium were mainly made in
the big bang and everything else was
more or less made in stars. you do it by
mass is about three-quarters hydrogen
one-quarter helium and a tiny bit of
everything else, so a few percent of
everything else.
so these are not to scale in that sense.
All right, but it turns out astronomers
do  actually know a bit more about
chemical elements and where they come
from that and in fact it's a very nice
graphic that be a little while ago that
tries to summarize it. it's caused quite a lot
of discussion and debate in the
astronomical community but at least  for a
first approximation it kind of tells you
what's going on. and it's sort of
reflects the story that I've just told
you that hydrogen and helium were made
in the big bang and pretty much
everything else was made in stars. now it
turns out course that that's not true
when you start looking in detail at
things. so for example when you start
looking at all the very heavy elements,
which have very short lifetimes. the only way we can
actually make that is by making them
ourselves. So anything that's made in stars has long
since decayed away so the very heavy
elements are actually human-made rather
than starmade and actually it turns out
when you look at the light into things
things are a little more complicated as
well because you've got things like
lithium and beryllium: you've got little
'c's next to them here. they're actually
made through a process called cosmic ray
spallation. cosmic rays are these very high-energy
particles moving through space and when
a very high-energy particle-- it could be
an atomic nucleus-- wacks into another
particle --could be another atomic nucleus,
you can actually have fission
occurring. that the atomic nuclei can fall
apart or something which was initially a
heavier element can actually be
splattered into these little bits we
believe the main way of lithium and
beryllium and boron get made is
through that spallation process. so they
weren't actually made in stars --well at
least something heavy was probably made
in a star, but then he got smashed to
pieces from cosmic ray interactions. the
broad story is that hydrogen and helium made
in the Big Bang, then you have stars,
stars in their center fuse lighter
elements into heavier elements because
that's how their powered. They're fusion
powered. and so you can make heavier
elements. one of the main ways you make
heavy elements in the core of a star
when you've got hydrogen turning into
helium and helium turning into carbon and so
on. but that kind of gives out at iron
because once you get to iron, then making
heavier things by smashing iron nuclei
together-- it turns out that absorbs
energy rather than giving energy out. so
you stop getting energy out of the
process when you get to iron. and of course if
you're trying to power a star, you need to
get energy out. so stars give up once
they get to iron. and so again the simple
law in in astronomy is hydrogen and
helium came in the Big Bang ,everything
up to iron was made in the centers of
stars, and then everything heavier than
iron only gets made it super novae
because when a star explodes then you
have lots of energy around you can have
these very inefficient processes. you're
not trying to power star anymore so
actually you can smack things together
and create the heavier elements like
gold and all the heavier things that are
around-- get made in super novae. and if you
look at this plot that's kind of true in
that if you just look at it
so we've got the green and the yellow are
stuff that's made in stars and you can
see all the lighter elements as we go
down the periodic table tend to be green in
nature till we get to about iron and
then they sort of start turning more to
this pinky orange color which is super
novae, and so you can see the more
massive elements tend to get made in in
supernovae. but interesting this is not
entirely true it's not like everything
stopped at iron and then suddenly
everything is made in supernovae. and in
particular if you look at these guys
here, i'm gonna have to struggle with my
command of the periodic table and
chemistry in general. that barium
lanthanum and cerium you can see they're
actually made in stars but they're way
heavier than iron right. Iron's somewhere
way up here and these are what down
towards the bottom of the periodic table
and so the question is how on earth you
end up with heavy elements which clearly
aren't made in super novae but are
actually all are made in stars
somewhere along the line. and that's where
we get to this thing called the
r-process in the  s-process. it's
actually quite hard to make a heavy
element because you have to take-- so if
you're gonna make a heavy element
through fusion you got to take two
fairly heavy nuclei and smack them
together and get them to stick. and heavy
nuclei have quite large charges
associated with them so you know
hydrogen only had one--
you know, one proton but by the time you get
to these heavier elements they have to
have lots of protons. they have lots of
positive charge, lots of positive charge so
actually they repel each other very
effectively. so it's very hard to make
heavy elements just by smacking nuclei
together. turns out there's an easier way
to make heavier elements which is that
if you've got a neutron, the neutral
particle, then you kind of make that
stick to a nucleas. so you basically
smack it into a nucleus, it'll stick and
that then add to the weight of the
nucleus. now you haven't actually changed
the chemical at that point because --so
chemicals that the chemical properties
of something depend on how many protons there
are on it, not how many neutrons are
on it. So adding a neutron to it just
changes the isotope of the chemical. it
doesn't actually change the chemical. but
neutrons can then decay through a
process called beta decay and the
neutron basically turns into a proton
and kicks out an electron and a neutrino
in the process. so you sneak the proton
in there by the backdoor? Exactly.
Without having to overcome these Coulomb
repulsions I've  managed to sneak a
an extra particle in which then
magically turns into a proton so i've
changed the element that way so it turns
out that's actually the main way. you
make these heavy elements just by adding
neutrons. and in a supernova there's
loads of neutrons around huge neutron
flux. There's a lot of everything around
a  supernaova; it's a complete mess.
and so you can have a nucleus and you
can just basically bombard whole load of
neutrons into it and then it'll end up a
very heavy isotope of whatever it
started with but then those neutrons
will go: bing-bing-bing-bing and will beta decay down into
protons so you can end up creating
heavier elements that way. and that works
great you can actually you know it
decays once and that moves at one place
at the periodic table because you added
a proton effectively and then it decays
again and so you can kind of walk your
way up the periodic table that way.
the problem is that sooner or later in
that process you reach a stable isotope,
one which will just stay there forever.
so it will decay for a while and then
it'll stick and that means that anything
kind of further upstream from that
nucleus you can't make anymore because
it you've got stuck at that point where
it's actually it's ...
everything's decayed as far as its going
to; nothing else is going to happen to it
after that so what I've just described
as a thing called the r-process, or
standing for rapid because you added a
whole bunch of neutrons very rapidly. now
there are other chemicals that that
exists in the universe that that are
kind of blocked by this process that
they wouldn't actually form from this
process. and the only way you can make
those is through this thing called the
s-process which is a slow process. which is
that you add a neutron, you wait for
it to decay,
it turns into a proton (it changes it) and
then you add another neutron, and you
wait for decay and it turns into the
next element up. and that way you you
don't have this kind of blocking effect
because you can always just had another
neutron and then it will decay and so on
so through that process you can get to a
whole other set of elements through this
thing called the s- process that don't get
made through the r-process, but you can...
there other decay chains that will
get you to these s-process elements. but
in a supernova everything happened very
quickly because you got this massive
neutron flux and then it's all over in,
you know, hours.
[Brady] so you only get one go to add a neu--
[Merrifield] Exactly and these decays if
you do this is s-process, you know you
added --you add a neutron sometimes these
decays can take weeks months years
thousands of years and so actually
you're never gonna-- that s-process is
never going to work in a supernova
because you've added one, and by the time
it's decayed to the next thing along, the
whole supernova's over. and so you're not
going to add any more neutrons. and so
things which you've made through this
s-process can't be made in supernovae. so
we have to look somewhere else where
there is this process where you can have
neutrons things but over a much longer
period of time
tens years hundred years thousands of
years rather than all in one go.
and it turns out that in the late stages
of some stars' lives, they actually
produce quite a lot of free neutrons.
some of the late-stage burning things
that when you're burning carbon into
heavier elements and we need to do you
actually get liberated quite a few
neutrons along the way. and so there are
free neutrons over the hundreds of
thousands of years that the the star is
going through this phase of its lifetime.
kind of ... bimbling around within the
star which means that you can actually
then, over time, add neutrons with these
s-process. these elements here that i was
talking about before: barium, lanthanum,
cerium, are only made through this  s-process.
and that means that the only way they
can possibly be made is that was
probably from a previous generations of
stars. there was a fairly heavy element
in the in the star, like iron or
something like that, which then had an--
late in the lifetime of the star, had
these this sort of free Neutron flux
bumping into it over tens of thousands,
hundreds of thousands of years, which
would through this s-process turn it into
one of these heavier elements like
barium. is quite interesting that that
whenever you get some Barium, you know
you know pretty much how that
has to have formed. then it's actually quite
a long story. [This is a rod of barium
we've got in here.] that must have been a
first generation of stars that went
supernovae, threw out lots of heavy
elements, that that will produce through
this r-process. but that wouldn't have
made the barium. then some of those heavy
elements were then incorporated into a
later generation of stars, relating the
lifetime of that particular star. there
was a strong one-- Neutron flux within the
star which would then through this
s-process get it up to these these heavy
elements like barium, and lanthanum .
[Brady] Quite a journey some of those atoms have been on
It really is and I you know it's kind of
astounding that just by sort of
understanding the nuclear physics and
how these various chemical elements get
made you can actually trace... you know
when you've got one of these elements,
you can actually look at it and say well
I know how this must be formed. and it's
quite --as you say it's a kind of
long, involved story and some of these
elements.
you should be able to file a
little bit of the barium onto this foil
ok I can see little bits coming off actually
they're very very small